oui mais bien vers d'ouvrir les rails et
des normales explique une histoire
marseillaise quand je parle de la chine
il ya toujours des intellectuels de
gauche ce qui est un pléonasme puisqu'il
n'a plus à droite pour me dire oui et
oui m'enfin quoi la chine chine la chine
quoi mais la chine est restructurée
grâce à des motivations interne qui
entraîne dans son moi subjectif un
clivage d'idéologie d'accord mais merde
parce que eh oh non parce que c'est pas
moi c'est pour moi ma petite dalle c'est
pas à moi mon âge avec tout ce que j'ai
vu j'en ai vu j'en ai vu j'en et j'en ai
je n'ai jamais donné j'en ai reçus j'en
ai envoyé on envoyait d'étendre les âmes
errantes la chine chinois masse aider
les gens qui sait des gens qui
travaillent aux panthères travailler
avec leurs deux mains c'est emmanuelle
sella chine et il faut pas la même chose
avec les deux mains avec la main gauche
ils construisent des barrages et avec la
main droite c'est la culture est ce pas
le petit livre rouge qu'ils agissent
sans arrêt avant de s'en servir comme
ils s'en servent jamais de l'agile tout
le temps mais il faut remercier mao de
n'avoir publié qu'un petit bouquin de
200 grammes pour éviter une surcharge
ont bradé chinois parce que si c'était
la rousse qui gouvernait la chine